previously on raft
there's a hole in the boat
guys I'm in I'm in a tizzy I can't seem
to plant cocoa nuts wait no if you don't
play coconuts do you don't you plant
seeds Palm seeds coconuts are food yeah
whoa there's a big island over there
though I see that it's a very big island
yeah it's a ship steering wheel oh hell
yeah oh gosh
do you guys want to go to vasagathan or
the Balboa Islands no uh
that's where we were and I'm out of
batteries batteries uh copper Ingot and
plastic we should have that yeah I'm
making the battery or should I make the
battery I sort of thought you were
making it because you talked about it so
much yeah
what does a battery mean what do we need
plastic and copper oh we have that we
can make a lot of batteries guys I made
a battery at the time it took me to talk
about making a battery all right 7038
got it all right I'm shark baiting so
that I can go and get all the harps hey
finished your bait and it left you
finished it yeah yeah you know
hey can stop hey can something
I uh I was literally swimming up through
a hole in the Rock and he missed like an
idiot loser hey I made a new bait it's
not working I can tell you I don't know
how to place it what do I do with it
let's throw it left click it throw it in
the water I did it thanks bud did that
work
nope oh maybe he missed me on purpose
and he's just going to go get the bait
now that he smells hmm if he comes and
tries to attack my bait I'm gonna show
him the what for yeah I don't want don't
let him chew on the bait make sure he
stays away doing other stuff ow why are
you still here he's definitely not
caring about this bait well that's
really working make him care your your
bait's gonna last forever yeah you have
to sell it okay you're the actor here
hey oh I've fallen and I can't bait up
please honestly he's literally swimming
around me in a circle just chomping at
me like an [ __ ] I don't know I'm in
the water and this Mark this bait is in
the water right yeah it's in the water
I'm not looking though but I'm guessing
Okay I see bait and it looks wet he's
coming
oh hey look at hey he likes my bait now
he cares oh good the battery's chewing
on the boat it just looks like he's
chewing on the bait not good is he on
the boat no no my concern okay all right
well
okay hey Harvest Time
what do we need what are you looking for
underwater do we need more I'm
harvesting all the oars I'm getting
metal ore and whatever we don't really
need copper but I'm getting all of it
okay we need metal we do need metal we
have 29 metal ingots but we don't I
don't see any yeah scrap metal it's kind
of like at a oh scrap metal we
definitely need yeah I'm getting all
metal all day all metal all should I
prepare another bait or do you think
that'll be enough we're probably gonna
need another bait we got lots of the
fishes you need for the baits uh well no
this is the last pairing and we got lots
of the fishes you need for the bait so I
hate to tell you this but uh we have a
lot of the fishes
no he wouldn't come over here that would
be rude he's not here anymore so he
might in fact he wouldn't come over here
because that would be rude and he's not
rude sharks have manners everyone knows
this oh my God it's okay Mom
bit me and not the bait uh Bobby's
leaving me and headed toward you and not
the baby fine he would not dare
he's not rude
guys
oh no that's some kind of warning is it
bad if I'm Browning and there's a shark
it's probably fine well that could have
gone better he does not care about this
new bait it could have gone worse that's
true it could have gotten worse thanks
for thanks for helping me see the bright
side yeah you're welcome man oh I'm
swimming into a cave with one quarter of
my total oxygen this is fine oh wait
remember your teachings about oxygen and
drowning
what remember remember the lesson you
said earlier guys I found a secret cave
with a secret Festival
is that bait or is that uh chewing on
Earth that's the bait it's the bait
maybe we should throw bait further away
I'm thinking about putting baits
somewhere else well it's really heavy
and hard to throw
hmm
we couldn't kill it I heard a bird no
okay I did not you did not that's damn
right you did not
I'm so sorry boys
to put up with this I can't believe it I
can't I don't know why I've ever invited
to things couldn't we kill it couldn't
we kill it I feel like we could get it
it runs away from the main attacks Bob
you wanna do it Mom's not in the water a
lazy yeah no I'm definitely not in the
water yeah
oh oh oh uh he's going on he's running
away
there's no way he's coming at me
directly
ah you know what I'm sensing a problem
with the plan
wow I'm really far out in the ocean here
aren't I yeah I see you I see you I was
so far away from Land of any kind he's
coming back well look we'll just kill
him we'll kill him good okay we'll kill
him yeah just just kill him
all right
I hit him good did it work is he dead or
he's gonna come back he's gonna take the
bait this bait's really close safe no no
don't say it reassuringly it's the wrong
answer there he is off to your left wait
ah
why did you jump in after it with your
spear from a distance oh yeah oh he
wasn't here
nice nice he's one hit his one hit nice
come on come on out
I got two hits but all he got he got one
and it was a good one I don't see him oh
there he is
I'll take one of these all right [ __ ] oh
what about this
yeah yeah I missed oh [ __ ] I feel like
Mark is having a lot of success not
leaping in every time the Sharks
we'll get this shark yet oh yeah you
guys it looks like you're making really
solid progress there yeah it's coming
it's coming I'm the bait no I'll be the
bait I'll be the bait I'll be the bait
I'm the bait I'm the bait
actually I was good okay I'm coming back
I'm hurt the bait is hurt lunch at me
I'm on I'm on land idiot you're the baby
where is he going I don't know he's
going to heal in his lair
I'm chasing him guys it's me and the
shark in a small area wow
hey guys that was a bad plan
I just want to let you know don't do
what I'm doing right now
I ran away I still have this bait that's
actually bait that we could have been
using this whole time he's coming he's
coming no
no no
yummy did it we oh okay yay and now he's
was he ever really there at all I don't
know existed
ah no we we know it is busted
what myth mustard
busted missed mystery sauce that's why
they call them the Mist Busters I get it
I never understood that name yeah you do
now you see it now you don't didn't you
know that
now you know huh Nostalgia anybody what
is that what is that from I don't know
Bill Bill who is that from Bill Nye I
didn't recognize that particular one
that was a specific segment where there
was just like a cutaway that was like
did you know that and then they would
say something and then be like now you
know all right you're right you're right
oh my God I'm the bird master I kill
every bird in one hit nice wow me early
hang your hat on that I'm the
that wasn't the phrase never mind bird
boy I'm gonna call you bird boy bird boy
sounds like the boy at the rich people's
Country Club who brings poolside fried
sparrows for snacks it's like pigeon man
Hey Arnold bird boy oh bad boy I have a
hobby I have a pigeon man who doesn't
know pigeon man probably most people
watching this video all right well
they're stupid and lame
anyone who doesn't know bird boy is an
idiot Loser yeah pigeon man but yeah
would you say that's from Hey Arnold
bird pigeon man yeah isn't the whole
thing about pigeon man on a roof in uh
City like kind of a cliche I added in
John Wick for you know Lawrence
Fishbourne
before
John Wick
it's gonna be crazy I don't know I feel
like the 90s happened before the 2000s
yeah but I mean like no the idea of a
pigeon man came that what I'm trying to
say is like it came probably even before
that before the 90s I don't know if
there were even pigeons prior to that ah
you're right what do I know not Birds
yeah you're right
you [ __ ] right you birdless [ __ ] boy
you're so right man I thought ass face
was bad until I met you yay I'm not so
bad
you birdless you need some birds in your
life
you're right you're right God when
you're right and you're so right I'm
gonna take your ladder up just to laugh
at you wow I can't there is something
blocking your life oh God damn it did I
put that there
that's fine it's fine hold on let's kind
of go around no if you can't shut up
there we go I'm out of nails oh [ __ ]
cool ladder guys thanks watch this
Wham there we go oh
is it back already
back yeah my bait's gone man those those
things is it time for us to leave
kind of uh probably and correct well not
okay let's go then I guess oh well yep
okay drop a lifting anchor really any
consistency either way would help I
think Drop It Like It's Hot dropping
anchor like it's hot guys I'm making
tummy sounds can I be honest with you
there's so much food so much anchor up
time to fish and flee fish and flea
confirmed is there really so much food
yeah
for days
go for it cook beets away I'm doing it
Daddy ass face there's five cooked
sharks and a bunch of the catfish in
this chest right here I can't hear you
because you didn't call me by my my real
name you call me by my mean name oh Mr
ass face yes thank you I'm so sorry hey
uh Mark which way are we supposed to go
hey that's way
what oh sorry I'll turn on the machine
ah
straight raw shark
all right you know how we weren't going
the right way before yeah no yeah we
weren't okay go the other way complete
wrongness okay well we need to like go
around the island yeah go around the
island okay yeah sorry where are we
going beats and we have eight sharks
shut up oh why are we cooking beets I'll
kill you
the mister from Mr ass face in a minute
how's that how's that direction Captain
Navigator man
ah let's see yep that's good I forgot
that it was oriented to the direction
that the thing was pointed and I turned
it 90 degrees previously
we're going to Blue excellent 703
excellent yeah it might take time it's
it's uh yeah we kind of we're not going
towards it at all before so that was my
bad that's gonna take a long time we
found that sick ass Island that was a
sick Island that's sick [ __ ]
oh I didn't eat there muted myself there
instead of doing the beep that one yep
fashioned way all right how about an
engine
yeah
yeah
we got a bunch of technological
advancements to make they're circuit
boards in one of the chests what else do
we need for an engine
stuff things maybe
I rope five metal ingots one circuit and
20 planks we've got all that I'm not
making it right now though
at least you clarified
appreciate it this time I didn't want to
leave you guys a stroke why is none of
our water processing well it's because
it is processing I'm just just get out
of the way I made another one just for
this I'm so thirsty wait there's a full
thing of water it was empty when I was
just down here it's crazy 100 full there
you go it's another one do you have a
water bottle yet wait or no I do but I
just choose not to use it in case of
emergency okay cool that's good don't
use that thing we've spent a lot of
money on that you know just for you we
gave that to you yeah you could use it
if you wanted to God no why would I do
that yeah I guess okay he has a point
there hey you're cooking shark meat when
we have all these beets shut your hole
hey speaking of sharks there's a shark
somewhere sharking us
can we stop what we're doing and go to
the island well we're headed that way so
might as well shooting from that Island
we need bees and animals
have bees minimals
that happened there's an island yeah
where we're going where you look if you
look there how there's an island when
you look at it he's got a point there
that's where you really gotta I like
that we can't turn our boat we just go
sideways I yeah I wish you could rotate
if only we built a steering wheel you
can you can you know what that works
he's right but you're right you're right
Mark yeah if there does make it turn uh
all right I'm not making one but we have
to pay for it we need 10 scrap four
ingots four ropes and one out of two
hinges or bolts I'm not gonna make it
either I'm just listening we have all of
those things
yes ah that doesn't sound right do I if
I either
am I doing this
Bob is doing it otherwise I would have
okay Bob's got it I'm not making it Bob
got it I'm making one and then throwing
it overboard put it in the scrap machine
crunch it into metal I'm gonna put the
steering wheel in the most useless place
I can on a giant Tower like 80 feet up
in the air yeah
I don't really want to lose I gotta be
honest I really don't want to live that
life again oh didn't you love The Climb
ish you know ish it was fun but also not
fun I see if you know what I mean anyway
things are looking up everybody we have
the wheel where where do we have that we
could put it in we could put the wheel
in the latrine I could put it in there
piloting is
can we get a heading check there yeah
heading check uh we we're now Road how
did we rotate 90 degrees away from the
wheel I rotated oh you turned us okay
um poof I have no idea I think yes yeah
we're good yeah
look man I don't know it's almost like
we're going the same direction but out
of the boat it's almost like this desk
should have been oriented at the front
yeah we're fine we're going to Blue
right I couldn't change it I could
change it I'll change look uh no don't
change don't change the way you are
changing mine changed oh okay well that
changes ruined my my battery no I I
grabbed the battery before I changed it
all good
[Music]
and there it is thank God I thought
maybe it was invisible no I I got it man
I thought it was invisible
this guy
I can't fit this over here okay it's
gonna hang weirdly oh okay she
don't look up over here if you're down
it's actually okay that looks incredibly
unbalanced actually no no no no no no
it's actually fine it's totally fine I
love how the heavy part of that machine
has no support it's fun thank God all
the way can be supported on those small
baskets it's fine
it's fine it's all good you are an
engineer I trust you thank you that's
what it's all about I want to see what's
so fine about it it's totally fine
actually
wait what's not fine this seems fine
yeah it's fine the recycling system has
no support in the heavy Parts looks fine
it's clearly bolted down yeah it's
bolted such a rumbly machine clearly
would be bolted
oh yes thank you
sorry I tried to I tried to not do that
but I literally couldn't stop myself
[Laughter]
that's the that's the uppercut of
herbalism right there oh good yeah so it
hurts so you killed it holy [ __ ]
yeah I heard you say it's less impactful
harsh words
feels better right yeah oh God I feel
like a million bees
uh
[Music]
uh I hear start attacking the right side
yeah
oh don't repair that or anything that's
fine wow the passive aggressiveness
needs to be yeah
oh don't repair that or anything
it's fine
see it doesn't hurt less Mark I you know
it doesn't everyone can feel good about
themselves hmm I don't ass face look I
we all love you whoa It's ass face yeah
it's better come on sorry ass face uh
but you know your butt and just throwing
another what if we uh what if we all
cooperated what if we all were look how
much water Mark has up here
Mark gave us poultry to water between
all of us and he's got two just for his
own self you [ __ ] ass
yeah that's not so bad then all right
okay yeah you greedy pass
if if there's if there's a mango tree
does it constantly get mangoes I'm gonna
tell you all right that's a great
question I imagine it's like the other
treasure to cut them down to get it with
the coconut trees yeah maybe I don't
know but anyway mango mangoes are
fantastic for food source they give a
lot of water and a good amount of food
we have that mango recipe too for some
kind of drink yeah we need bananas uh
the mango Nana well we'll get banana
trees up here soon I've got enough room
for a third row of trees in between here
I'm kind of like trying to plan ahead
for it but we'll see oh man
can we make a course correction uh do
oh wait
no ah
I don't which way is North which which
way is North I don't know you have to
turn right wait a minute
we need to turn left
we need to rotate left
150 degrees Yeah Yeah that turn right a
hundred and more than that do you want
the navigation thing down there
no no it's much better if it's hard
[Laughter]
yes I'll move it down there
what that wasn't me that wasn't a joke I
was just being it's this is how it's
always been I assume this is how it's
supposed to be yes why am I drifting is
anyone else drifting am I drifting yeah
I'm rotating really aggressively right
now all right I was just wondering about
that uh here I'll put this right here
okay don't mind the cables it's like
fine it's fine
what's the other big fish other than
cats requires how this requires iron
see it has to be like that I couldn't
possibly move the steering wheel and
sail up there you're right you're right
I'm such land oh really we're heading
right toward an island okay uh of course
recorrect do a little bit to the right
do a little bit you got it boss say when
all right I'll say when
Salmon's a fish
and almost
there
five really drifted me right now four
three two one
all right we did it okay good nailed it
that's good for me salmon is a fish wait
you're right I meant this the other bit
but we are turning a little bit aren't
we whoopsie are we still turning for a
moment let me see where it's five this
is fine that's fine about six times you
can be a little Lefty Lou but it's fine
it's not that bad all right well land's
no longer hoe who cares about the land
someone probably not me
oh the shark
oh
so sad it's okay man
he attacked us personally
something breaking okay no I'm chopping
trees I'm good I cooked a catfish here
let me put let me cook the important
stuff do you see what I have in my hands
to put on the grill yeah I see it you
[ __ ]
yeah
hey
that's getting a little hostile here
guys I don't know I don't know how I
feel about that
slowly I got some news we are running
out of palm tree seeds uh they don't
give as much more every time they they
don't give a like other plants do they
sometimes it's like a 50 chance of
getting a seed so I only have uh
I'm gonna do a round of mangoes because
I have just enough to fill up for that
and then we're gonna see where that gets
us damn it wait I was cooking beets yeah
I'm eating them all well I'd have way
more if you'd let me do my job I'm doing
a better job of getting a sustaining
food
I don't think you need to soften the
blow on that one I gotta be honest
I did it for dramatic effect
oh
what sale I'm just gonna put that shoe
right there to catch the extra catfish
juices guys we've survived 22 days ooh
uh we deserve it I'm gonna do a thing
okay hold on I'm gonna do a thing okay
uh
uh
interesting that was so much easier than
I thought it was
um let's see
damn it ah there's a hole Mark
you put it right where I was about to go
why did you do that you're uh I'm so
sorry
sticky
[Laughter]
ah there's an edge mark why would you
leave the edge of the boat oh it's
getting bigger
ah are you edging right now oh yeah
I was inside of it oh my god well you
really are oh man oh wait
um we need to build more uh I need to
build more platform there's not really a
good place to put that I guess you keep
it on the other side
[Music]
well it's not funny if you
I found it funny
okay I find me hilarious
oh I'm glad somebody do
me too
ah this is perfect is it a photo of me
oh it's gonna be
Wham how about that look at that land ho
you got your engines right next to your
wheel here see that's really convenient
yes
it's just losing you there's no pleasing
oh you could fix it oh you can make it
better oh it's I guess it just wasn't
good enough when I was made it the first
time I'm fixing it it's fine the way it
is
it's literally no it's fine the way it
is oh I see what you're doing oh Mark
those mango trees up here nice mango do
you know what Mark now oh it's for shark
y'all now it's perfect bye mark thank
you that's what he's doing something
Wade's yelling a lot I don't know what
he's up to yeah I don't know hey look an
island
oh [ __ ] yeah guys I found an island
I'll chop down the trees guys
wait why don't you make yourself useful
start harvesting
I grabbed a crate that's not a tree wait
what we really need is wood right now
okay come on I'm on it oh you do have to
chop down mango tree okay interesting
yeah why don't you throw a hook into the
water and just leave it here
what there's a hook just chilling in the
water right WoW shark bits me there's a
shark too yeah that's still a shark yep
I thought you guys didn't say there
wasn't one all right one more tree oh
fine yeah though this is very cool and
all but
how do we make biofuel
uh oh right biofuel that's what we need
for the engine
um
we'll leave it I put the reinforced
things I like it I like the spot yeah it
actually it's like in the right spot for
a uh engine in the back that's very
strangely appropriate it's true it is
true yeah damn it I have this big salmon
I'm just oh throwing over my shoulder
like a dick carrying it around flopping
in the wind I don't know if that's how
that is or how that works you've never
flopped the dick catfish before have you
no actually I've never no yeah no so
don't talk until you flop I'm not all
right don't worry I'll keep cooking
chicken it's not going anywhere ah damn
it oh the chicken's done way did you
need the grill oh yeah that'd be great
I've got this bigger do you guys need me
to nudge the boat so we can just keep on
the journey damn it yeah uh yeah all
right let me just get out oh my god did
anyone just see what the anchor did what
did it do it like launched up out of the
water through the through the upstairs
portion of the thing it's very funny
well you didn't have to rewind it that
dramatically
frog you know as though I do guys as I
do as it was all about holding beats Bob
no reason about putting more beans
I've got my cooked fish you don't worry
about it [ __ ] fish don't eat
nasty soups no no nasty soups you're
insulting my soups yes oh my God if you
get soup anymore
you ain't your stupid ass fish how does
that feel yeah where's our clay why
don't we have any clay we do have Clay
what do you need before we left the land
hoe huh we have Clay I was just gonna
make some bowls so I can make more soup
that's probably a good idea soup that
weight isn't allowed to have what what I
do oh he's an [ __ ] I mean you you you
you you insulted my suit there are no
Planks on this Grill you're just trying
to find something you're just storing
your fish there well it's better than
where it was before no it's not it's not
there look I planked the fish
how are you seasoning this how is this
marinated what are we having a little
bit of sweat my shoulder that I was on
for quite a while and the natural
ocean Musk
sounds kind of good I guess yeah it does
sound kind of good but I'm gonna be
honest oh don't you dare [ __ ] off Barrel
I will [ __ ] you
oh
excellent excellent uh yeah what are we
doing uh we're still going with the bees
we still are not anywhere close to where
we need to go but it's all right it's
chill though it is Chill though we got a
shark
does it feel though not it not chilled
chill unconfirmed whoa bro he was going
after the engine bro bro all right Bob
you can have the grill
I don't want it now we can make another
Grill uh we're on heading 775 775 away
from our destination we're good
it's kind of beautiful up here if you
think about it if you look at everything
it's really pretty it's potato potato
it's really nice guys
let me just take a moment to think
it's nice
no time got a fish I like how we have
the world's most faded Pirate Flag oh is
it yes it has a skull with um with hooks
on it and it looks like a priority flag
but it you could literally barely see it
I didn't know that it faded that's crazy
guys there's a light in the distance
light in the distance
what the frick got the moon is it the
moon oh that the moon yeah the moon's
over there oh my God it's the Death Star
I don't this feels uncomfortable what
are we doing does this take place on
Alderaan oh I hope not
how do we get mango seeds does if you
eat a mango do you get seeds sometimes
is that what sometimes do you get seeds
if you when you're chopping down the
tree I think sometimes you can see yeah
I just got one but I would think that a
mango has seeds in it you'd think that
you'd get a seed from the end every
mango have a [ __ ] huge seed in it
yeah apparently not in this game
watered good we have new wood God we
have so much material this is weird
we're not usually this well off yeah we
are very well off to the point where I'm
having like did we set this up like easy
or something no I think we just reached
a point of maximum capacity so many
mangoes God eat mangoes and coconuts
there's just too many
bird I got uh Kate's gone
I don't know why I didn't kill it that
was my my bad my bad wow you just I'm
trying to cook and eat the beets and you
have so many goddamn Beats
yeah beats is uh these things grow God
damn fast it's probably why they took it
out of the trash compactor but I bet the
biomass is gonna [ __ ] love the way
these beats oh that's true
right yeah instead of coconut we should
be loading up on beets
yeah wait there's a light in the
distance there's a light in the distance
you're right you're not an idiot
this time it's blinking it's blonking
sure go away it broke a corner shark
broke
according to the bird nest Corner oh God
damn it did we lose that bird nest
yes did we lose the other thing that was
on it
who dropped their their hook in the
water and just left it there that is bit
I told you that's been there that's been
with us for a long time man this is
ridiculous I have my hook though I don't
understand what happened I think we all
do I don't know where that one came from
yeah it's very strange I wonder if I
scoop faster
if we paddle
we'll get there quicker I hear a bird
eating your stuff but I'm not I'm not
doing anything about it if we all paddle
are we like super fast I have 75 ropes
in the storage with the scrap metal so
if you need rope don't make it or I do I
guess because all these are useless
otherwise but wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
land boat rap thing wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute this
looks familiar mark this isn't a thing
oh who changed the number
none of us oh no
oh no no
oh no we're not oh no
I don't know I think when I moved it
because I moved it up and down it must
have changed oh God all right let's
we're yeah we're heading there
we're only two kilometers away guide
I'll battle oh man I can't believe we're
here I'm paddling block a new character
here I'm battling I'm battling as well
don't worry all right if we all paddle I
bet if we all pal we got all this
material we might as well paddle right
all right yeah let's do it we're so fast
probably
[Music]
let me check the see if this is like any
faster
[Music]
you're so fast oh
all right
good paddling boys it is good battling
ah my paddle broke don't worry mine's in
good shape where's the battle where's
the Goddamn battle there is wooden rope
I guess I gotta make some more rope oh
[ __ ] well I'll make some more I got it
I'll make some more oh don't what Mark
all right I made don't forget idiot
[Laughter]
it's too late for me guys three boys
just working on the rack
you think if we made more sales we'd go
faster 100 is that confirmed because I
swear we know that they're not paddling
God I haven't been here full time you
just noticed you haven't been battling
this whole time God no I know
I don't have one make one here I'll make
you some rope ready Wade ready here we
go there it is grab it grab it grab it
you got it all right good
all right wait a minute
what's up what's up we'll get there so
fast
story The Bees think of the bees we need
to get to the bees
I was working real hard on things I
wanted to do but I guess I'll do all the
things you want it's what we want
okay we want this Wade yeah what if I
get you some nice head wait I'll give
you some head if you I'm already doing
it so I'll take the head on top of it
sure wait the to meet me in the latrine
well then I can't paddle but it does no
here come here close the door oh close
the door
there
what you doing
nothing in here hey what's up all right
okay
paddle face all right Bob you want some
uh
yeah close the door close the door
okay
what'd you do it's right there it's
right there
oh thank you you're welcome you're
welcome all right everybody paddling hey
Mark you're drowning me with the
battling oh no okay oh God oh God he
doesn't have just go go in the anchor
hole in the ankle no no
okay we're good
foreign
we're actually almost halfway there guys
if we were all paddling think of how
quick we'd get there this is teamwork
everybody
this is quite bad look how quick the
items are what
go
so wait stop handling for a moment
where's the anchor hole okay
Whistle While You Work
oh that's sad that's really
really there's an island over there but
don't be distracted it's it's against
God
no don't hold that land
what if it has bees no we don't care it
does not it doesn't have bees does not
have beers
doesn't have bees calm down this is so
fast guys I'm so proud of us
I have to admit that I am really hopeful
that we somehow end up back at the giant
boat why would you hope that because
it'd be really funny for the content I
is so long as you guys said that the
Balboa Island is where we're gonna go
the Balboa Island right I have no idea
we want the young Grenada that's that
other one
no what's the one word One what's that
one
that's the one are you wait no
yeah that's where we want to go
no I want to go to Balboa no this one's
the crew wants to go to Balboa so he
clearly wants to go to the wrong one
Balboa no Balboa no we're going Balboa
the second gang whatever that's a
vasectomy Island are we wait I'm I'm
confused now which one do we actually
need to go to we need to go to Heaven no
we're going to Balboa Island that whole
time I wasn't paddling guys because when
I put the weight on my mouse I looked at
the sky and apparently that doesn't work
don't worry I'm actually paddling now
though so now we're gonna get to the
vasectomy Islands quicker it's a Balboa
Balboa Island the beginning in London I
thought we want to go to the
vagina Elegance
Valiant gentleman Island let me look and
see how we're doing oh we're 800 meters
away we're doing great we're doing great
guys now ignore ignore it ignore it
ignore it lead us not into temptation oh
bird I'll be back [ __ ] off bird those
were our buds
they're probably beats no there's
potatoes up there oh one of your crops
we're fine we're fine whoa there it is
there it is there it is something big
loaded in